ah you ever had one of those days where
you just tired for no reason yeah all
the time
okay well no one asked I'm having one of
those days so therefore can't send up
for some reason so therefore today we're
gonna watch a movie for cringe Tuesday
[Music]
cool care cool cat cool cat it's made by
Derrick Savage
the perfect representation of a kids
movie go get cool cat is an
anti-bullying movie and cool cat is the
coolest cat in the world you can tell
this guy just wanted to make action
films but somewhere along the line you
just end up becoming a cool cat
[Music]
cool kid kids superhero cool cat kid
superhero cool cat kid superhero that's
the actual name of this bill fun trivia
if you click trivia here it says that
the original title was cool cat loves
you but was changed to cool cat the kid
superhero after Derrick savage read an
article saying that the only movies
doing well are superhero related and
inside of that kids needed a superhero
go cat superhero
this is classic example of Derrick
savage genius he breaks the law he
breaks the rules of storytelling it's
show don't tell doesn't exist here
painting a picture I am painting picture
making YouTube video faking YouTube
video I am making YouTube video hello
everyone my name is PewDiePie
I'm making YouTube video touch more he's
not even painting I've comes Derek what
are you doing hey I'm just painting a
picture I like how he calls him daddy
I'm gonna practice my new rap song cool
cat rap master wow that sounds cool
would you like me to do the mixing board
for you thanks that'd be great
but in then why don't know what is
happening paint a picture now I may grab
some oh that's awesome
do you want you're the waiter do the
mixing for you I can produce the song we
can release an LP yeah I can we shoot
the whole video right now let's do it
let's go I don't I think it's safe to
say I don't have high hopes for this
song why does it sound like he's about
to molest him no one likes opening doors
for anyone that much spoilers the reason
is because a cool cat
and open doors because of his giant
fingers he keeps referencing this
throughout the camp let me get the door
for it
just open the door you don't need to say
it why do I care
hey so what you go understand up there
behind your microphone so we have a good
time there you go buddy
Oh to record a lot of people don't know
this you need to stand behind the
microphone stand over there behind the
microphone
all right cool cat I'm ready okay let's
go some rhymes one two three how long is
this film how long is it well an hour
twenty five surely the rap can't be that
bad his name is cool cat about the
coolest cat yes that doesn't even rhyme
you couldn't even rhyme the first line
you can't write anything with hop pop
shop stop Jesus Christ cool cat and the
kids loved him so so you better watch
out cause he's an anti-bullying hero
oh my god changing the game changing the
rap game the flow he's the coolest cat
and I love him so and he's the best I
can't because he is great a hero wow
that was great
Wow and I'd love to be creative just
this is what I've said so many times
stop being create them stop it stop
being creative not good it was plastic
bottle in the trash oh wow I guess I did
no no we should always recycle and I
love to recycle our cans and bottles and
it's good for the earth and that's you
know you're right cool can't I tell you
what it's great to recycle and I'm gonna
start right now here you go son add this
to your collection is that some sort of
joke I'm gonna start recycling here you
go he even has a little bottle that says
all cats recycle bin I learn me back up
Wow
I sure love a lot of bottles here
bottles bottles come on and hop on this
fancy bike and I'll help you get on here
just going to get this bad boy running
right here we are gonna crash
[Music]
so it's so clear to me that this is just
some sort of way for this guy the
director and the writer to just show off
whatever it is he wants to show off you
know initially I thought this was a bait
I thought this wasn't actually real I
thought this movie he was one of those
movies purposely made to be bad that's
not the case after some examination it's
not the case so they go these motorcycle
bike for no reason I think everything in
this movie happens for no reason I love
exactly that was super duper cool
I loved it thank you daddy Derek and
Glenn well you know what I've got to get
inside
whose gland hmm all right so cool cat
calls his friend they decide to do
something hi Maria cool cats in the
kitchen I know will make you sanctum
they're awesome I know I saw I mean
great job you guys have fun now okay hi
Maria I love it with pretty outside I'm
in a work area with the white get some
more psych supplies oh please have a
seat
everything is great they're having a
great time but then the bully this is
the coolest office I've ever seen you're
outside outside is not an office someone
told you this cool cat you don't know
about this cool cat gets a dump picking
on someone and look of it is if it's not
cool cat ammonia they pick this so cool
any of the kids that doesn't have a
speech impediment sorry
so how does he bully this girl well he
sends a text saying she looked ugly
basically that person's just a big big
bully oh hey cool cat I just got a text
from the same person should I open it
you know maybe they feel bad about that
really mean text and now they want to
apologize he's trying to make him feel
bad at this point come on cool cat hello
this is cool cat why did he call you
don't get my text no one understands you
a debater don't don't stop sorry I'm
making fun of kids I'm basically what
cool cat is trying to fight against I
get that I get that I get they Oh daddy
cool cats so brave yes he's a real crime
fighter why do you want to paint the
wall like that it looks like butch what
you hold in the can yeah I guess so
you know my parents have a saying with
friends like that you better not have
any enemies
so why do you want to paint me loves us
we tackle all things
so that they know we were there nobody
cares for us that's why we don't care
same for me the blatant racism because
no one loves me the truth is there's a
lot of people that love you and care for
you I know because I love you I'm cool
kids hear that whisper why do I have to
say what is my life I know because I
love you I'm cool kid I don't know why
the orange cat is yelling at us I know
because I love you I'm cool kid go cat
then teaches the kids about in Taiwan
all periods thank you for caring about
us you know what I have a saying true
integrity means you do the right thing
when no one is looking in other words be
cool yeah let's have some integrity and
clean up the sandbox that we take I'm
down with that in that's bruising and
remember you have their kids power you
can be anything you want to be you start
work on and make it happen and that's a
saying you can take to the streets yeah
yeah let's be something cool don't
understand yo
it's always really good in the movie
when you get to see someone walking down
the stairs
that always makes a good movie if you
get a full sequence of someone walking
down the stairs then I don't care you're
adopted kool Kat he's not even a cat
that doesn't make any sense
hello wow this is great
until kool Kat right now and thanks
kool Kat goes to Hollywood for a meeting
and they're doing a parade that's the
plot line I am NOT gonna show it to you
because nothing happens they enter car
and then they leave backwards with the
car you can't leave backwards it's
called returning yeah I've got something
wonderful to tell you we're in Hollywood
someone asked me to be in the Holland
parade what what's he talking about I
know honey but I was there and it's the
real deal what I just want is watch cool
can walk down the stairs again and I
think that's all I want to see yes good
do it cool Ken do it walk down the
stairs yeah he's doing it again
he's gonna do it is he gonna do it is it
gonna do it I wanna see who can go up
the third okay go up the stairs
go go go up there's all these goddamn
feature films that it has to have the
title feature film because it needs to
be an hour and a half or whatever I
don't know what that the rules are but
they don't they always have these drag
that sequences god damn god like what is
States whoo my daddy's practicing wicked
hits he could very good cardio training
very good cardio training watch and
learn
[Music]
he's the one that made the film he
wanted to set this up for a kids movie
okay okay whoa why we Wow okay I'm just
gonna this is too much even for trans
Tuesday's how do you like this dialog
right here for your song oh oh that's
looking good God loves to rock yeah cool
cat loves to rock cool cat loves to play
the guitar and he looks so cool cool cat
loves to play the drums yeah and he
plays them so good so there are actual
lyrics okay this is kind of a spoiler
but when they sing the actual song
they're not singing the lyrics
[Music]
cougar
is that a cool keychain I thought the
kids will boogie to that song is it me
or is cool cats mom kind of hot so it
looks like the parade so they just
hijacked someone else parade but then
they are actually in the parade and I'm
just like what is his parade cool cat is
the creation of Hollywood's very own
Derrick Savage
cool cat and his adventures are featured
in several children's books including
cool cat loves karate as well as a new
video project called cool cat stops
bullying cool cat is holding me at
gunpoint cool cat is the greatest movie
like how he brought his camera for this
event but the shots that he gets of the
audience it's just like actually worse
quality than my videos it's always so
weird to me like this guy clearly tried
to create some sort of concept you
probably put a lot of money and time and
effort into it it's you know in a way I
feel bad but also cool cat I don't know
so all the sudden tables are turned here
that the bullied becomes a bully and
they added as a trivia character error
despite the matter yeah and cool cat
said earlier that bullying is bad and
shouldn't be done so it done she is
later seen bullying butch by making fun
of him that he is not invited to the
house of vivica a fox then all the
sudden Erik Estrada is acting in one of
the scenes I don't know who he is but
apparently he's that he's the guy hey
who's that kid no probably want to cool
cats friends
all of cou cats friends are cool that
kid looks like he's up to trouble one
cool cat kids are cool
that kid however not cool better not be
a bully because I don't like oh it could
be your bully this time I want to talk
yeah I want to have a word with them so
cool cats tip to stop bullying is to
just say leave me alone Annie worked
shoot I wasn't able to get them over
there neither the dog Vivek a box and
eric estrada messed it up I don't
understand a single word that you're
saying because no way to get cool cat so
we ate escape to nothing yet they hurts
oh no it's push the pulley these are
dirty little bug this will be stamped
it's up to you cool cat go save the
children yeah go get him cool cat what
is he saying
Oh God go cool cat kill that child
please he jumped over the candy
and the cops arrest a child that's right
everyone how do we stop bullying I just
let the cops arrest the bully that's all
that you need to do this sends a great
message and how to stop bullying I never
seen any more better ideas
oh no the cat they got me you going
through the ranch kid I feel like it
would be a lot more forgiving to this
film if it actually had some good
anti-bullying message that I could
actually kids benefit from so then the
movie takes it really really really
really weird turn cool cat finds a gun
now you can shoot the bully defense
somehow they mess it up and their bully
gets the gun
cool cat wakes up and is like I don't
want to go to school the bully is gonna
bring the gun to school I dream I dream
that push the bully brought the gun to
school
oh don't worry about that cool cat I'll
be with you kids so everything will be
okay don't worry about that you should
still go to school code cat what the
hell and there yeah and he brought the
gun to school
okay kids don't panic and just stand
beside me I'm scared
yeah I don't want to get hurt don't
worry it'll be all right my teachers
will help are you sure I know our
teachers will help they care for us this
is some sort of thing about teachers
being armed in school now is that what
is this going oh thank you guys I just
feel a lot better to be with you okay
kids come on let's get inside in school
they'll help us so call the poll that
everything will be cool because the
police they're our friends just cops
we'll get those guy to guys come on kids
let's get inside come on out come on
come on come on come on cool cat come on
Oh bonehead put the gun down put the gun
down right now Judy says watch don't be
stupid
took the gun down don't be got me again
they got him again they just got him
again
what so the kid just goes to jail how
does it stop bullying I'm so confused
look the problem is over problem over
kid in there the kid the kid comes back
the kid that went to jail comes back
from jail but I'm sorry okay
and thanks for apologizing but how'd you
get out so fast we saw a policeman get
you my mama got me out and she speak by
the book so they go through all the
things they learned and they realized
that there's no stopping ability long
and hard about this and with
cyberbullying you can't really stop
cyberbullying do anything about it
that's bull cat everyone thank god they
know the answer so if your no I'm Derek
savage and I'm the creator of bull cat I
hope you really enjoy the video and I'd
like to introduce you to our cool cat
family first
here's cool cat hi if you want to be a
cool cat don't be a bully and this is
Miss vivica this makes me wanna bully
hope you guys enjoyed this video smash
like subscribe almost out of a hundred
million and I see you guys next time bye
there ain't no hate in all this grace
because cool cat is full of love for all
this mate
what you never played to purr simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]